I think the Bitcoin ETF is a troan horse
yeah it's it's basically turning Bitcoin
into a trafi asset something that
basically plays by the rules of the
system but by doing so it's being used
to onboard the system that that's it's
the perfect Troon horse and it's going
to end up in the for one case of
millions of people that otherwise would
not have this exposure and just having
that Bitcoin there is going to make them
think about it and they're going to
eventually many of them going to align
the the fact that they hold Bitcoin with
the fact that they're deeply unhappy
about how is going down they're
going to connect that Bitcoin is
actually an alternative it's an
alternative to the
system all right guys bang bang I've got
Alex here uh I thought a great place to
start this conversation is a recent
tweet that you put out and I thought it
just was a perfect epitome of the
current situation you said let me tell
you why I remained very bullish on risk
assets inflation is coming down interest
rates as well the US economy remains
strong soft Landing is becoming a
reality Trump will win peace talks are
in the Air China just turned doish after
two plus years quantitative tightening
will end in 2024 Global liquidity is
increasing and Aid driven growth is in
the process of accelerating to a point
that human mind can't even
comprehend is everything just go up from
now like is that where we're headed just
risk assets are all gonna go up I do
think so I do think at the same time
that on the short term the market is a
little bit too hot kind of like the the
example the analogy would be uh uh this
uh looks like June last year uh where
about to I think uh pump up a little bit
more and then correct but but like it's
uh I think it's important as an investor
and a Trader trying to differentiate
between uh shortterm Trends and and and
the bigger picture and the bigger
picture and the larger Trend it is uh
based on on on on what you just uh uh uh
paraphrased uh it's it's up and uh
strongly up uh short term definitely
right now the market is a little bit hot
the way to think about this is this is
mainly driven on the risk asset side by
the fed peot from December so we are
literally seven weeks into into into
that expansion and it's been pretty
significant so it's mostly in the price
the pivot and the soft Landing narrative
is becoming consensus is not yet
consensus there is a lot of people and
they make me bullish every time I read
them that that firmly believe
that the economy must undergo a severe
recession uh based on basically a very
limited sample size from uh uh past uh
past crisis and uh one one more thing uh
to add there or at least one more thing
is when we're looking I think when we're
looking at trying to anticipate what the
future is going to be based on what the
past has done and the sample size is so
small and and stretches through such a
long per period of time like the sample
starts with 1929 right it is not correct
to put the same waiting it's this is
very subjective but I I firmly believe
it's not correct to put the same weight
to events that happen in 29 than in uh
59 than 81 than 87 2000 2020 and and
right now because it's a different world
it's a different Market the FED is an
entirely different animal with' so many
tools at their disposal before they just
basically manag the FED fund rates or
the discount rate that now they have the
ability to do so much
more uh something else uh uh on that a
couple more things um
Trump I think Trump will win I'm not
Republican I'm not a Democrat I'm not
even American um if I would uh if I
would uh
vote um in the past I would have voted
Democrat uh since uh in the last few
years I I be I I have gone to the right
uh I would vote Trump nowadays even
though I'm not a fan of him uh but
living aside preferences and Views uh I
strongly believe that Trump will win
it's going to be a home run for for him
his campaign is extremely well organized
this time unlike prior times and uh he
has a very weakened adversary on on
Biden and even though the the US economy
is actually strong and much stronger
than than than many people think
there's something else which is uh
perception is not in line with reality
because of how strong inflation has been
and was between 2020 and
2023 not any longer they are most people
are unhappy there and and also there is
something else this the inflation has
also driven a a big wetch into society
and that Society us American society and
actually worldwide societies becoming
more and more polarized between the hals
and the Have Nots what that means is not
that the Have Nots vote for Trump what
that means is they vote against the
status quo because they are unhappy so I
think Trump will win and uh uh
historically actually Democrats are
slightly better for stock markets than
Republicans but there is something else
there which is Trump is obsessed with
winning and obsessed with the stock
market so uh I I based on that I think
Trump is good for the market uh uh and
uh some something else um sorry I keep
on saying something else um um the uh on
U something else that Trump will likely
bring up is a threatened Federal Reserve
he's going to bring back let's remember
this ghost that that we experien on on
his presidency I think it is likely that
he will go after the FED again and
threaten their
independence what that translates into I
believe I may be wrong but I believe
that that basically pushes uh interest
rates short-term rates down and
long-term rates up uh basically a more
dobish fed when they shouldn't be as
dobish As Trump will want them to be is
going to basically literally uh bring
short-term rates down and uh and uh
inflation fears in in a in a a a
backdrop of of basically
exorbitant uh debt issuance in the US
should I'm not I'm not certain actually
if if long rates are going to go uh down
but not as much as shortterm rates or
actually up I lean towards the former
but it could very well be that they end
up going up the point is f uh yield curb
steepening and uh that is
um that is I I dare say is is largely
good for risk assets uh in aggregate not
great but is very negative for the long
long end of the curve and also for
mortages and so uh I'm not painting a a
disaster scenario it's just a driver
that makes things not as rosy as they
would otherwise would be I just just one
last comment on that it's it the US Deb
right now is growing about 6% per anom
it's absolutely unsustainable you know
yeah you know um everybody knows well
well so we we just saw the Federal
Reserve chairman Jerome Powell say that
on 60 Minutes right and where normally I
said you know they don't somebody in his
position wouldn't kind of fire at others
in leadership positions he's kind of an
independent uh he normally would just
say hey you know I don't have that much
to say about this um but to say it is
unsustainable over the long run uh seems
like it was almost he was issuing an a a
warning he was telling the American
people hey you should be paying
attention to this and when you see uh
the national debt now over 34 trillion
the interest payment alone has now cost
over a trillion dollars a year how do we
reverse this or how do we get out of the
situation in your opinion uh I think it
comes uh it's about econom it requires
very long-term change uh in the economy
uh in in economic behavior by market
participants it takes a it's going to
take a very long time but there is a way
out I think there's only one way out
which is basically growing and growing a
lot so uh in a way you we could think
and and and try to to make an analogy
with what happened in the late 90s
with the Bill Clinton administration uh
the US actually run for a brief period
of time uh fiscal super rabit uh it is
feasible but we've gone the the US
economy and the world economy has gone
so far out that uh it's going to take a
long time and it it's basically about
growth and I think that's a reality I
think it's going to happen because it's
uh uming it back to to AI um the market
uh Market commentators tend to think and
and especially traders that it's
overrated that uh AI is not going to
solve all our problems and yeah they're
right but AI is the it's in my view and
I I I I I'd be surprised if I'm if I'm
proven wrong in 10 years is the most
significant change in uh
history and it's going to happen at the
fastest pace of any change in history
the change is going to be so dramatic
that we cannot even understand how
things are going to change because it's
not going to be us anymore thinking
about this it's AI right
so it's it's uh that's another another
thing that ties into this thinking of we
should not be extrapolating the past as
we have we need to be open to this time
things may be different and in fact this
time things have already been different
when it comes to the yield curve
inversion that basically got absolutely
everybody bunkers almost everybody
bunkers and calling for a very hard
recession um um since uh literally
started in 22 and went all through 23 uh
and it didn't
happen this time is different one of the
places where there is radical change
underway or an attempt at radical change
is Argentina this a country that you
understand well uh you spent a lot of
time thinking about uh I believe
um and Malay has come in there and he
was elected with a very clear I'm going
to go Implement radical change uh for
what I can tell as an outsider it
appears that he has already taken some
steps some measures that he's trying to
implement and kind of fulfill the
campaign promises so it wasn't appears
to be just talk but he's actually trying
to act on it what is your analysis of
him his you know kind of campaign
promises and whether it can be
successful like can he turn that country
around uh um well I'm born in Argentina
I grew up there um I'm Argentine I'm I'm
what you would Define what people may
Define as Argentine diaspora uh
Argentina has had a long history of
Crisis after crisis um from the
generation that left uh uh in the early
2000s uh when uh basically the uh the
the socialism took took over the country
again after the the Argentine peso
imploded and uh we abolished the
convertibility law that had PC to the
dollar one to1 I was in fact actually
working at the ministry of Economics at
the
time
um so uh that that said I am uh I I seen
mle it's crazy it's it's the first
politician in my entire
life that I feel connected to uh he
speaks to me uh it's uh I I do believe
that governments are
a bloated parasite just sucking our
blood and uh that's what he's that's
exactly what he's trying to achieve is
like going after the bloat going after
all the parasites and get it rid of them
and uh how successful can he be it's
difficult because he has very little
support in Congress he has under eight
under 10% of congressmen are his uh with
his Alliance is uh his uh the
congressman he has are in the low teens
it's nothing so the way I see it is he
has to
survive he needs to survive the first
two years and go into the midterms that
going to happen in two years and then
basically change the shape of Congress
to actually be able to deliver what he
wants to do um initially I was placing
odds of uh him to succeed at around 40%
I think it's higher now higher than that
that being said
it went from
0% to 40 60% Argentina
was let's put it this way if the Argent
GDP has grown about 30% uh GDP per
capita in the last uh uh in the last 20
years uh the US GDP I actually forgot
the number but it's considerably higher
uh China has done a 10x India I think
has done an 8X Russia has done something
like a 5x I'm I'm pulling these numbers
a on my head be easy to to check them on
Google but we get the trend uh every
other single country in Latin America is
has their GDP per capita by at least up
2X and Argentina has stagnated and it's
uh the 134th or 140th poorest country in
the world on when it comes to that and
if you go there you're going to find a a
city that is uh the the capital buar is
beautiful is vibrant people are very
intelligent very educated uh incredible
country huge natural resources
everywhere how is it possible that
things are not working and the answer is
it's
socialism it's a country that where
socialists have sucked them dry but
there is it's some people get offended
with the word socialism and we have to
differentiate there is good kinds of
socialism responsible one well managed
well implemented without theft and then
you have the Argentine socialism and the
socialism that we see in Latin America
which is basically run by thieves so
when you go so deep down the hole
uh an economy enters what we call a
poverty
trap and the only it's a like a
perennial negative feedback loop from
which There Is No Escape you're stuck
there and the only way out is through
what I call a shock therapy an external
shock something from the outside needs
to happen that's melee it's an outsider
and he's there to break things up and
try change so um that that's how I see
it I'm I'm I'm extremely happy about it
and and by the way let me allow one one
one more thing pump there it's things
are really bad in Argentina right now
it's inflation right now is running at
almost 1% per month after melee uh it's
it's there is no money it's things may
even get violent on the streets because
of this but unfortunately it's uh it's
there's no money it's sacrifices need to
be made I mean and and when you talk
about sacrifices mle leads by example he
flies commercial even coach inside
Argentina who does that it's it's
absolutely mind-blowing like he has a
presidential plane a huge boing that
that plane is sitting in a hanger trying
to sell
it it's that's what leading by example
is I'm I'm fascinated by it yeah so we
see Malay and Argentina doing this
buelli in El Salvador seems to be doing
a number of similar types of things at
least the outside you know external
shock uh he may not be as inflammatory
in his retoric or U you know uh be able
to articulate it in the same way but one
okay people pay attention two we only
need one more and then it's kind of a
trend is that really kind of how you see
this playing out is that we should
expect more of these external shocks
that the uh various countries their
population are going to elect because
they're fed up or or they feel like
there is no hope inside of the existing
system
yeah I do I do now now this doesn't
necessarily mean a move to the right I
think it's more about uh polariz
political polarization is whoever is
whoever is on the left goes to the right
whoever is on the right goes to the left
we saw that actually in Chile uh about
uh it started in 2020 uh we had Chile
even even they've been changing the
Constitution to basically make it more
fair to distribute profits to the masses
so uh I'm not a Chile expert
unfortunately my Chilean Chilean
audience forgive my ignorance but I I
know that's that's been happening so the
point there is that it's not just about
a move to the right it's we we're going
to see a move to the right in the US uh
we're going to see a move to the right
in Europe uh this year I think uh we
just saw it in Argentina we saw it in
Ecuador um in some other countries we
see exactly the opposite I think it's
it's about that and about whoever takes
over has to be an outsider uh we saw in
Ukraine with selinski selinski was a
comedian right a TV
star that um uh makes Trump zalinski uh
you can go to Malay you can go to bukel
I mean you can go around the country or
around the world there's a lot of these
how do you think that um assets like
Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies play into
this in one hand the promise of these uh
Technologies and assets was it would be
outside of the system that uh if you
bought this it was a way to exit to off
ramp and you know kind of almost produce
an external shock yourself for your own
portfolio or your own bank account um
but at the same time that they're
becoming popular they seem to be getting
pulled back into the system we see the
Bitcoin ETF we see you know now Wall
Street hedge funds Etc starting to trade
in these assets how are you looking at
this asset class I you're spending a ton
of time here right now given you know
the economic overlay the political
overlay what's exciting or where where
are you really focused this episode is
brought to you by freck historically the
wealthy had a hidden secret in investing
they would spend a lot of money and use
very big teams to conduct tax loss
harvesting tax loss harvesting is the
timely selling of Securities at a loss
to offset the amount of capital gains
tax owed from selling the profitable
assets later but now frk is bringing
this incredible advantage to any
investor they'll literally lower your
tax bill regardless of how much money
you have they use state-of-the-art
technology through a product called
direct indexing to allow investors to
invest in the S&P 500 while getting all
the benefits of tax loss harvesting
without the big Bill if you want to
learn more go check them out at fre.com
that's
fc.com I'm a big fan of the product and
I even became an investor in the
business frk.com go check them out today
I think Bitcoin the Bitcoin ETFs aside
of being massively bullish for things
I'm sure you've been discussing
extensively so everybody is on the same
uh we're on all on the same page here uh
I think the Bitcoin ETF is a trojan
horse
yeah it's it's basically
turning we're we're we're we're turning
Bitcoin into a trfy asset something that
basically plays by the rules of the
system but by doing so it's being used
to on board the system that that's it's
the perfect trogon horse and it's going
to end up in the for one case of
millions of people that otherwise would
not have this exposure and just having
that Bitcoin there is going to make them
think about it and they're going to
eventually many of them going to align
the the fact that they hold Bitcoin with
the fact that they're deeply unhappy
about how is going down and they're
going to connect that Bitcoin is
actually an alternative it's an
alternative to the system that's what it
is so that's that's how it ties up um
yeah what about other assets um stable
coins or other cryptocurrencies do they
follow that same trajectory of Bitcoin
is the Trojan Horse and then here come
all these other assets right behind it
or are they something separate and
different I think it's separate and
different it's a matter of educating uh
people all all the other assets are
things uh we crypto natives uh dealt in
uh they're very hard to understand take
a long time to understand they're
complicated they it's uh difficult
execution everything is difficult around
them so uh the way the way I see it is
uh basically money flows into Bitcoin
and then it it trickles down into all
other crypto assets but at the end
conceptually uh most of the good ones
not all they're the same you know then
we have stable coins stable coins they
what stable GES do it they they reduce
inefficiencies right but at the end they
are or they're soon there's some
somewhat regulated assets they will
eventually fully regulated uh Regulators
have full control over basically they
can go to tedar and circle and make them
Blacklist
addresses um so stable coins do not fall
outside the system like Bitcoin
does
um there is yeah it's the way I think of
of crypto here is it's on one hand we
have the the store value on the Bitcoin
on the other hand we have uh payments uh
on the other hand we have the uh the
ability of blockchains to deliver fast
settlement and generate liquidity for
for assets uh in in general uh when
people claims that there is no uh there
is no intrinsic value there and and they
get so upset and and you can just we can
point at any of these things or just say
listen just the fact that it's trading
247 and offers liquidity 247 that's
value you cannot get that anywhere else
uh and uh then we have uh we go into
minan coins and yeah that's just a
speculation but people likes to gamble
uh so uh uh mean coin are casinos right
uh and uh so it's it's not just garbage
much of it is garbage but there is there
is value uh under the trash um when
you're when you're evaluating these
things how much of it is fundamental
analysis how much of it is more
technical analysis um how how would you
describe your kind of evaluation process
and and what you're using to get to sift
through you know garbage and trash
versus the things that may have some
sort of value it's mostly uh for me at
least it's it's mostly talking to people
um to trying to assess where where the
market is going where the market may be
going and uh if if uh projects have good
teams not teams what people I know how
people I know and respect greatly in the
space they they think of not the project
itself but is the team has it does the
team have integrity or not um so not
really asking uh and wondering where you
think the price of this things is going
to go but more of who is
behind um so yeah technicals matter uh
it's I wouldn't want to go against the
trend for too long when that happens I I
do what is called basic Ally puking I
just puke the whole position and get out
um um but um yeah it's a combination of
technicals fundamentals top down mcro
View and uh and try to think where where
what the market likes uh things like for
example bit t or tow uh on the gamify
there's quite a quite a few games that
are really good there is some really
good uh out layer ones a layer layer
twos in the market uh some already out
there like core cord Dow uh there are
that no nobody talks about it but it's
there uh there is uh and there's new
ones coming up we have monad we have
Eclipse uh uh Aztec in in uh q1 25 uh uh
taii there's a lot of innovation
happening in the space so it's it's yeah
sorry I could not provide a very very
explicit uh mathematically precise
answer but it's like a holistic process
no but I think it's important right it's
not one thing to point at like part of
finding the value is you have to do the
work if you talk to a value investor in
the public markets and looking at
equities many of the best investors you
ask them well how'd you find that and
they say well I sat and I read you know
the 10K or I read the s1s I read all the
uh the q's and the ks and like I just
went through all this stuff and I
basically figured out exactly what uh I
thought the company was worth and then
it traded below that and I had a
prepared mind and I was able to go and
buy it at the right timing you're may
not be reading a you know a public uh
letter or a public file from a crypto
project where you're doing a lot of the
similar work you're trying to
triangulate what is the uh value of this
and also what is it likely to do in the
future and then you're making investment
decisions where you're risking Capital
so I actually think there's a lot of
similarities more so than maybe people
realize yeah yeah I agree we've um yeah
just need to roll up the sleeps and and
and get to work yeah when you say
something like uh take I think you
mentioned core I know nothing about that
but uh you say it's there and people
aren't talking about it how important is
the social conversation and the memes
and the uh you know what I consider kind
of the de uh Degen um coalescing around
an asset in this market we obviously saw
GameStop and other things and you know
public markets uh trade very differently
because there was this surge of interest
from uh nonprofessional capital
allocators is that important here or can
you actually look at and say hey we
think that this is a really interesting
asset we're going to buy it and even if
those people never show show up and the
memes and the culture doesn't come we
still think we can make money on an
asset I think is uh extremely important
um it's an attention driven uh uh
economy um fundamental value of most of
these things is very hard to quantify
with any kind of precision so it's very
subjective and uh most things out there
they never get to the public eye so it's
really it's about basically the ideal
world is having a a team and a product
that are very very very good and then
bring the spotlight onto them but
without the spotlight that this these
projects can have the most amazing Tech
that if they don't know how to engage
with uh the the marketplace um the the
the the marketplace of basically who has
people who have money basically uh to to
drive prices and drive attention great
examples of this is let me pick a a
recent example so for example on cordal
cordal is it's a a pretty significant uh
layer one it's a Bitcoin e hybrid so
proof of work proof of stake they have
insane engagement numbers but it's
mostly Asians and people from the
Emerging Markets real people from
Emerging Markets there is very little uh
attention from the West on them uh
another one uh and that can change right
a capable team can change that
another example that is quite
fascinating is what's happening with
Trump let's pick I'm not I don't I try
not to shield in fact I don't have a
position on Trump but the Trump mcoin
it's it's just a mcoin has very little
liquidity it's it's there and there
comes a very significant Market Market
participant in the market and says I
believe in this thing I'm putting my
Capital behind it for a and C reasons
and suddenly goes from being an absolute
unknown coin to everybody and every chat
room talking about it and suddenly it's
the in a good way um so yeah it it
matters a lot how how teams uh
manage um public exposure how do you
think about portfolio Construction in a
world where assets can be so asymmetric
but also there can be kind of the
classic rug poles and and things can go
down very quickly as well is it a
heavily concentrated portfolio is it
something where there's more
diversification you're trying to just
you know more like a a venture Capital
portfolio trying to get power laws to
take over even though you know some will
be losers how do you do it for me it
varies greatly and what I do for myself
is not what I would recommend for other
people uh honestly uh because I'm a I'm
a very extreme risk
taker um so um I wouldn't say do what I
do uh I think everybody should have a a
a very significant exposure to crypto uh
I would say somewhere between 5 to 10%
none of that 2% thing that's that's
nothing have some
bolts um but uh uh when it comes to that
is uh it it should be mostly uh for most
people I think it should be mostly
Bitcoin eth and soul and a few uh uh
alternative projects uh out uh lar ones
like things that are very liquid because
the thing is with the most liquid things
as you will
know they can something bad can happen
overnight and the thing drops 90% and
never recovers they can get hacked or
somebody in the team may have access to
the private keys and there is an
internal hack uh and he takes over the
treasury and he dumps the coin and it
just never
recovers
um uh when it comes to me it's uh I'm
I'm right now I'm I'm 70% of my book is
BTC e and so quite evenly
distributed uh the remainder is uh all
over the place uh literally all over the
place uh game ify uh trying to get
exposure on on the AI side uh Ono on the
rwa side um uh a lot of uh l1s and l2s
it's yeah the rest is all over the place
it's it's quite a lot of basically
spread and prey
um yeah and and then some narrative
trading which is kind of like
conceptually different it's like you
have cash in the area and then you you
put a trade for X number of days or
weeks try to get that 10 to 40% and out
let's talk uh ethereum
salana say monad maybe those are like
four assets that you know generally are
in a similar area I think that there is
uh a very hardened group of ethereum
holders uh or ether holders um they
remind me a lot of Bitcoin maximalists
just they're holding ether instead of
Bitcoin um some people would critique
them and say hey you're going to miss
other things because you're you're part
of The Ether religion uh then we have
salana which seems to have become you
know the prettiest girl at the dance and
then it crashed ever thought it was over
but it's come back and showed some
resilience and now there are these new
uh projects that uh want to do these you
know parallelizations and uh kind of go
and say hey can we take these ideas and
improve them how do you evaluate okay we
have four assets they're all generally
in a in a similar bucket should I buy
one and try to pick the winner should I
just buy all four and say hey it's so
asymmetric that like just get exposure
all four and whoever goes up the most
great how do you think about you know
actually putting a position on in in an
area like that I think you have to have
a lot of conviction to just pick
one um I I I breathe crypto and uh well
macro well but it's like I'm almost 247
on this and I still don't have the
conviction to go uh all into one and
just ignore the other ones um so uh it
it requires a very special mindset to
just big one and also very very
extensive knowledge uh there are people
who do it very successfully like for
example there is famous uh famous
well-known influencer on on on Twitter
that's gone all in on on to bit tenser
and hats off it's been it's remarkable
um but it's it's that's difficult uh on
what you said about eth I I I think eth
is
fantastic uh I agree with you what you
say about eth Maxes uh there they're a
little bit
more rational e Maxes than BTC Maxes but
they're still they're Maxes sorry but I
don't mean to I don't never want to
offend people but
maximalism it it's being uh it's it
implies marrow n said me uh implies
inflexible inflexibility and that's
never good it's good to be to be able to
change our
minds um on on eth uh right now right
now eth is doing very well today because
Ian ler uh re opened their um uh lifted
their Caps or reopened their their risk
taking program uh I forgot about the
exact number but it was a very
significant number so so eth is now
undergoing a a a move of like let's buy
eth to put into igen layer for for
raking and then basically more or less I
I gather in four months whoever
rakes um so you get your e you stake on
uh on say Lio or one of those and then
you restake the the that token the
liquid token into igen layer and in say
end of H one you get points from I layer
that eventually they are transforming
into tokens and the the expectation is
that that's going to yield about 50 to
150% uh uh based on I layer valuation so
that's a shortterm move I think uh then
we have the ETF narrative uh that may or
may not come true in May uh the the
market is expecting right now
probability of 60 or maybe even 70%
right now that it gets approved in May I
think it's too rich I think for that to
happen we need gansler out and uh that
happens when Trump wins but I maybe
wrong um Solana offers fantastic
Innovation and and product Market fit
today
just went down today you know I don't
know how many hours four or five so e
Maxes are having a uh a good day um I
think Solana is fantastic and uh it's a
it's a proven winner with the other ones
let's put it this way there's there's
three chains that have a real community
and is a community it's not hot money
going in and out Bitcoin e Solana that's
it all the other ones are are ghost
chains for now say you mentioned say I
just used say for the first time uh last
uh last week it was a disaster um my
transactions wouldn't go through there
was verely any volume so it was not a
matter of hey the it's a launch things
are going crazy my transaction doesn't
go through no just didn't go through um
I think um Esa has very low TBL Aptos
has very low TBL there is very little
money on these chains and it's hot money
um you mentioned monad monad is monad is
a new chain and is extremely they
they've been doing an extremely good job
on
the marketing side on basically
capturing the Mind share of crypto
seters uh Traders and investors so I
think not only that monad is going to be
doing extremely well but also has a
chance to achieve what other
chains like say and and and sui and
Aptos have failed in doing which is
building a new
community uh that's that's very
important ab and sui unfortunately for
them they launch in the midst of like
Suicidal Tendencies in crypto like the
the depression extreme depression it's
over so they failed to they just got
unlucky they they they failed at at
building
that I know what do you think of that
actually I'm curious about your thoughts
there how do you see that I think that
um
maximalism uh is not true on a macro
basis it can be true in a silo so for
example uh I think that Bitcoin is the
winner for uh the global store of value
right like you become a money maximalist
I always use the example if you grew up
in the United States you're a dollar
maximalist you get paid in dollars you
save in dollars you buy in dollars you
pay your taxes dollars Etc but if you
grew up in Mexico you're a peso
maximalist right like you know it's kind
of that that is the thing and so this
economy for sure Bitcoin is that store
value it wins and so being a monetary
maximalist makes a lot of sense uh but
confusing the rest of these assets as
competition to bitcoin I think is wrong
they're just you know technology
evaluation right same that you would do
with public companies you would never be
like you know I'm an iOS maximalist I
don't think Android's valuable I may
prefer iOS but I don't it's not I can't
say Android's not valuable and so same
thing here um and I tend to think that
uh portfolio construction is really
important but if I was to boil down from
like the the the essence of you know how
I view investing today macro matters and
Global liquidity crypto is really just a
trade on global liquidity then you look
inside of crypto and it's if you are
investing in the crypto sector you
probably are fishing in the right pond
if you're not or you have a very small
allocation you're probably just going to
miss out performance because you're just
in the wrong Pond uh and then within
crypto there's really a bifurcation
there's kind of the Blue Chips those
blue chips will continue to do well uh
but as they get larger their returns
will go down so you know people who
thought that the Bitcoin ETF was going
to get approved and then we're going to
hit all-time highs you know I I said it
beforehand I went on television and
talked about it I said look you know
maybe but also I I you know would
caution that that might not happen um
and then the long tail is is early stage
Venture right a bunch of them are going
to be zeros some of them will win the
ones that win though will uh likely if
you build a a portfolio correctly be
power law drivers that end up paying for
the losers and so just got to ask
yourself you know what type of investor
are you and and frankly I think a lot of
people uh they don't have the time uh
they don't have the interest or or the
energy that you or I would have to go
and spend you know all day long thinking
about this stuff talking to a million
people trying to figure out you know all
the the latest uh Trends they like look
okay I'm going to take you know 5% 2%
whatever the number is I'm just going to
buy some Bitcoin maybe I'll buy you know
one of the other ones and uh let me know
how it goes I'll look back in five years
and for them guess what they're doing in
the rest of their portfolio passive
indexing in the S&P you know Q's like
they're just that's the way they invest
is they're kind of passive indexers and
so um I don't think that we should
critique them or yell at them or or any
of that stuff I I think it's just you
know different people do different
strategies and and that's okay uh you
just got to be comfortable with what
whatever strategy you
pursue y 100% And and something you you
said I fully agree on on on the fact
that Bitcoin is uh is an entity by
itself it Bitcoin has has some
competition from eth but not from the
other ones eth on the other hand has
competition from
everybody so that's that's an issue
that's a that's a problem for e one
other thing that um I often think about
and I'll say this with I don't know 80
90% confidence is you know people would
critique Bitcoin and' be like oh it's
the first one it's the AOL right it it
can't survive and obviously if you go
and you look like people have been
trying to create a digital currency for
a very long time it's you know 40 years
after the first attempt frankly right
Bitcoin kind of breaks through so it's
it's not the first one it's more similar
to Facebook being like the 22nd social
social
network but I do think that ethereum
actually is the first attempt at kind of
a smart contract blockchain and uh so in
a weird way Bitcoin being you know the
the result of 40 years gives it strength
ethereum being the Pioneer in a new way
to do this actually may be a weakness
doesn't mean that it'll fail doesn't
mean that you know it won't be valuable
in the future doesn't mean the price
won't go up like like but structurally
actually Bitcoin is not the first thing
and ethereum is the first thing in their
category and so thinking through the the
pros and cons of that is pretty
interesting that's a very good point I I
I have to say I haven't thought about it
this way uh and I think you're right
yeah very very good way to put it you
know like in some way the the critics
say that Bitcoin is AOL but and again
I'm not saying that this is 100% true
but actually is ethereum AOL and salana
already showing it's the second you know
quote unquote social network it's the
second search engine and the Googles the
Facebooks the you know the 20 30th 40th
iterations of these things that end up
being the the real winners those are yet
to come again I I don't know I know just
enough technology history to be
dangerous right so I'm not even an
expert on that but I I do think that
these are the uh components outside of
just evaluating the community outside of
the technology outside of the
fundamentals of the assets and the
markets themselves trying to look at
history and how has it evolved is pretty
important here as well because um I
don't think that human Nature's changed
and and I don't think that these
technology waves has necessarily changed
either so else in Bitcoin I'd like to to
to add is uh the the top route uh
upgrade is it the of of B I think it was
a December 22 that opened up the way to
to ordinals and and this whole ordinals
layer to bitcoin wave and
uh it it literally solved the main
problem Bitcoin had which is very low
fees and what do we do once mining
rewards evaporate now there is finally
these guys with their JPEG and
eventually much more they they they
actually it's not what I think is they
they they brought in uh a solution that
that that works and uh also I I perceive
that that space is has very little
penetration in in mind share it's like
nobody outside of crypto notes about it
and uh most people in crypto still they
don't they're not interested in that
space because they perceive that they
missed the beginning and it's too late
so that what that means is there is a
lot of room for for uh for a growth to
show up on top of Bitcoin still I said
it's very early I think I completely
agree and um in a weird way uh I think
there's been a narrative from some over
the years that like the altcoins were
R&D for Bitcoin and that seems to be
playing out in that specific use case
doesn't mean that you know kind of alt
coins Etc won't be valuable or find
their own use case is but uh definitely
I think that bitcoin's layer 2 activity
in tapro ETC has learned a lot from what
the altcoins have done has seen a lot of
use cases and in some way is copying and
trying to Port back over some of that
Innovation um which is exactly what a
great company or a great organization
would do right is you you Pioneer some
yourself you you solve some problems but
then when you see somebody else doing
something that's working you don't have
too much pride to incorporate that as
well and so I think that um that also
shows bitcoin's ability to adapt to you
know market conditions and and
incorporate other Innovation uh as a as
a positive as well yeah that's the
beauty of it I mean like it or hated a
big number of these things are copy
paste uh you can't copy paste the the
the underlying chain but all the
applications are copy paste or not all
but large number a lot of them yeah a
lot of them for sure um Alex I can talk
to you forever where can we send people
to find you uh on the Internet or uh
find out more about what you're doing on
a day-to-day basis um the easiest way is
um actually the only way it's just
Twitter xx.com
um Kruger macro uh and uh I yeah I'm I'm
oftentimes there I enjoy tweeting uh
actively and um engaging with people on
direct messages that's that's a way I I
I have for learning about what's going
on I I love following your Twitter
account because you're one of the only
people who is we enough to have the Dual
interest of macro and crypto and so one
day you may be talking about global
liquidity or you know a foreign central
bank and then the next day you may be
talking about a random blockchain that
you know everyone's talking about and uh
uh I tend to think that um that is where
uh outsize returns are going to come
from in the next you know 10 years or so
uh so so I think that you're on to it
and people should definitely go give you
a follow if they haven't already thank
you I appreciate it very much of course
all right well I appreciate your time
very much and we will do this again in
the future
awesome thank you